Das, was ein britisches Forschungsteam jetzt
in der Antarktis entdeckt hat, ist wirklich
ungewöhnlich.
Eine Fläche von 50000 Quadratkilometer Eis
ist schon abgesackt - zurück bleiben nur
riesige Schmelzwasser-Seen.
Die Erklärung dafür sind wohl radioaktive
Gesteine, die sich unter der Eisschicht befinden,
und das Eis von unten nach oben schmelzen
lassen.
WHAT!?
Was man bisher zu dieser mysteriösen Anomalie
unter dem Eis weiß und warum diese Entdeckung
wirklich tragische Folgen für die ganze Erde
haben könnte, erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction; herzlich willkommen!
Als das Team des britischen Polar-Forschungsprogramms
“British Antarctic Survey”, kurz BAS,
eine Region in der Ost-Antarktis überflog,
trauten die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
wohl ihren eigenen Augen nicht Denn dort war
eine Eisfläche von gigantischem Ausmaß,
nämlich etwa fünfmal so groß wie Berlin,
verschwunden.
Der Radar, spürte stattdessen riesige Schmelzwasser-Seen
auf, die sich unter der Eisschicht offensichtlich
kilometerweit erstrecken.
Die darüber liegenden Eisschichten sacken
also immer weiter nach unten ab.
Die Ursache für all das sind nach Vermutung
der Experten wohl ungewöhnliche radioaktive
Gesteine, die eben für diese großen Schmelzzonen
sorgen.
Diese lassen die Basis des Eis quasi von unten
nach oben schmelzen.
Dazu Tom Jordan, der Hauptautor der aktuellen
Studie: “Dies war ein wirklich aufregendes
Projekt, denn hier haben wir eine der vielleicht
letzten noch unerforschten Regionen unseres
Planeten erkundet.
Unsere Ergebnisse waren ziemlich unerwartet,
da viele Leute der Meinung waren, dass diese
Region der Antarktis aus uralten und kalten
Gesteinen besteht, die die Eisfläche darüber
wenig beeinflussen”.
Dieses Phänomen ist laut des Forschungsteams
allerdings nicht unbedingt eine neue Entwicklung.
Die Eisschmelze, die jetzt beobachtet wurde,
könnte demnach schon seit Tausenden oder
sogar Millionen Jahren in Gange sein.
Dennoch könnte das zusätzliche Schmelzwasser
in der Eisdecke die Region in Zukunft viel
anfälliger für äußere Faktoren wie den
Klimawandel machen, so die Befürchtung der
Fachleute.
Zudem ist es laut der aktuellen Studie ist
äußerst wahrscheinlich, dass solche lokalen
Anomalien in der Ostantarktis weit verbreitet
sein könnten.
Und das könnte zu einem großen Problem werden,
denn um vorherzusagen, wie viel Eis an den
Polen verloren geht und welche Folgen das
weltweit haben könnte, braucht es exakte
Daten.
Doch die aktuelle Entdeckung zeigt, dass wir
in diesem Kontext noch lange nicht alles auf
dem Schirm haben.
Die großen Schmelzzonen in der Ostantarktis
beispielsweise sind in keiner Berechnung enthalten.
Doch auch ohne dieses neu entdeckte Phänomen
ist das Problem des Schmelzens in der Antarktis
groß - wir berichten hier bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction immer wieder darüber.
Erst im Sommer 2018 hatte ein Forschungsteam
der University Leeds eine besorgniserregende
Botschaft verkündet: Demnach hat die Antarktis
nämlich von 2012 bis 2017 im Mittel 219 Milliarden
Tonnen Eis pro Jahr verloren!
Eine unvorstellbare Zahl und fast dreimal
so viel wie in den Jahren davor!
Das muss man sich erst einmal vorstellen:
Das Eisschild der Antarktis hat seit 1992
also insgesamt etwa drei Billionen Tonnen
Eis verloren.
Mit dieser Menge könnte man ganz Deutschland
rund acht Meter hoch mit Wasser bedecken.
Doch eben nicht nur die reine Wassermenge
an sich macht den Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern so große Angst.
Sondern eben auch die Geschwindigkeit: 40
Prozent des Eisverlustes passierten der Studie
zufolge in den vergangenen fünf Jahren!
Denken wir mal den Worst-Case; dann nämlich,
wenn das gesamte Antarktis-Eis schmelzen würde:
Der globale Meeresspiegel würde dann um unglaubliche
58 Meter ansteigen!
Eine Katastrophe - nicht nur für die Küstengebiete
auf der Erde… Wir stehen also kurz vor Alarmstufe
rot, denn schon jetzt sind einige Veränderungen
in der Antarktis nicht mehr rückgängig zu
machen.
So kurios die jetzt entdeckten heißen Quellen
auf dem ersten Blick also erscheinen, umso
klarer steht auch fest, dass sie dringend
genauer erforscht werden müssen!
Wenn es neues dazu gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich
hier oder auf dem englischen Kanal.
Da gibt es heute die Videopremiere: Making
plastic from plastic waste - Are Bioplastics
the solution to global pollution?
Sehr interessante Lösung für die Plastikmüllprobleme.
Ich freue mich auf euch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
Stay tuned, see you soon!